يزور الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب الرياض
يتحدث في محافل عده عن خطر ايراني وعن
ضروره توحيد الجهود الاقليميه في مواجهه
طهران يرد عليه الايرانيون بالصمت احيانا
وبعبارات مثيره في احيان اخرى لكن ثمه امر
اخر كشفت عنه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز في
تقرير يشير الى صفقات امريكيه ايرانيه
تجاريه تقدر بالمليارات وتوفر الاف
الوظائف للامريكيين قد يقول قائل انها
عقليه رجل الاعمال حين يتولى مقاليد
الامور في اي بلد وقد يرى اخر ان ثمه
غموضا استراتيجيا في السياسه الامريكيه
نحاول ان نفهم ما يجري في محطه الحصاد
الثانيه والبدايه بتقرير ناصر اي ال
طاهر مصدر الازمات والخراب في المنطقه
خطرها لا يقل عن خطر تنظيم الدوله بل هي
راعيه الارهاب الاولى في العالم تلك هي
ايران كما صورها الرئيس الامريكي اخيرا
خلال زيارته التاريخيه الى الشرق الاوسط
فماذا بعد وعيده بان لا يسمح لايران
بالتحول الى ق عظمى نوويه وبان يعمل على
كبح محاولات تمددها في الشرق الاوسط نظريا
ثم استراتيجيه لعزل ايران مجهوله المعالم
يريد دونالد ترامب دول المنطقه شركاء فيها
لكن اذا صدقت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه فان ثمه امورا تجري تحت الطاوله
تقول الصحيفه ان زياره ترامب الى الشرق
الاوسط لم تؤثر على الصفقات التجاريه بين
طهران وواشنطن
بالرغم من التصعيد الكلامي المتبادل
بينهما تستدل نيويورك تايمز على ذلك برده
فعل طهران على تلويح ترامب باستراتيجيه
العزل فقد جرى تلقفه بهدوء تصفه الصحيفه
بالمثير للدهشه في العاصمه الايرانيه اما
السبب برايها فهو ان اداره دونالد ترامب
اظهرت في الممارسه العمليه استعدادها
للقيام باعمال مع ايران هذا مثال على ذلك
بينما تشت نبره التصريحات في الجانبين
ينتظر الايرانيون تسلم دفعه من طائرات
البوينج في اطار الصفقتين التين وقعتا مع
الشركه الامريكيه احدثه ابرم بعد شهرين من
تسلم ترامب مهام منصبه ولذلك ربما تفسير
سياسي وتجاري فالرئيس الامريكي الذي قامت
حملته الانتخابيه في جزء منها على وعود
باحياء العماله الصناعيه لن يفرط في
مشروعات قد قادره على انشاء 18 الف فرصه
عمل في بلده قضيه اخرى تثيرها الصحيفه
فخلال الحمله الرئاسيه وصف ترامب الاتفاق
النووي بين ايران وقوى غربيه بانه اسوا
صفقه على الاطلاق ولكنه وقع خلال الشهرين
الاخيرين بهدوء على تنازلات حاسمه عن بعض
الجزاءات بما يبقي الصفقه ساريه هل يعني
ذلك ان الامريكيين مطمئنون تماما ايران
تقول الصحيفه ان المساله الوحيده التي
تشغل الاداره الامريكيه وتقلق هي اتساع
نفوذ ايران في المنطقه لكن هذا شيء وضروره
حفاظ البلدين على الاقل على علاقه عمل
بينهما شيء اخر والاعمال تقضي بفتح قنوات
اتصال مباشره ان امكن فوفقا لنيويورك
تايمز سيكون من الصعب على الولايات
المتحده حل مشكلات لبنان وسوريا والعراق
واليمن من دون ايران ومع سيطره الولايات
المتحده على الاقتصاد الايراني من خلال
العقوبات سياتى الحصول على تنازلات من
طهران في القضايا الاقليميه يقول
الايرانيون انهم لا يزالون يحاولون معرفه
نوايا ترامب ربما لانه حتى في الاعمال
يتصرف على نحو متهور وغير متوقع لكن حين
سئل وزير خارجيته ماذا لو اتصل بك نظيرك
الايراني عبر الهاتف اجاب ريك تيلرسون
طبعا ساتل
الاتصال ينضم الينا من واشنطن البروفيسور
دانيل سروار استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه جونز هوبكنز ومن لندن عبر الهاتف
المحلل السياسي محمد قواص مرحبا بكم سيد
دانييل سروار الرجل الذي وصف طهران هذا
الكلام منذ ايام منذ اسابيع ربما ليست
بعيده وصف تهرم بانها راس حربه الارهاب
العالمي تماثل في خطرها خطر تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه الذي استدعت كل جيوش العالم
تقريبا لقتاله الان يقر ويبرم صفقات مع
ايران بعضها
بعد بعضها يتعلق حتى بالعقوبات الامريكيه
على المشروع او الاتفاق
النووي الايراني كيف نفهم هذا
التناقض الا يحاولون ان يحصلوا على كل
الامور يحاولون ان يحققوا افضل المكاسب
يريدون ان يعقدوا صفقات مع ايران ويريدون
ايضا ان ينتقدوا طهران كلما تسنت لهم
الفرصه اذا ما استطاعوا تقديم حصول على
ذلك وتحقيقه فهو امر جيد كيف يعني كيف
يمكن الاتكاء على التحالف مع اداره سياسيه
بهذه المواصفات
اذا
اعتقد ان باستطاعه الاعتماد على واشنطن
بان تكون عدائيه للايرانيين لكن لا اعتقد
اننا نستطيع ان نتكل عليهم بانهم سيتنازل
عن اي صفقات من اجل ان يضغطوا على ايران
والحصول على تنازلات لكن اذا ما كان هنالك
مفاوضات مستقبليه بين ايران والولايات
المتحده لان
الطرفان غير رابان بال اتفاق النووي لربما
سيكون هنالك مناقشات استاذ محمد قواص هل
يمكن بناء على هذا فهم رد الفعل الهادئ من
قبل طهران على الصفقات الضخمه التي ابرمها
السيد دونالد ترامب في المنطقه عندما كان
يزورها يعني انا رد الفعل اولا ان ايران
من خلال ال يعني ابرام على صفقه لشراء
البوينج وسؤال كبير لماذا ايران تشتري
البوينج الامريكيه رغم ان الولايات
المتحده تعلن بشكل واضح عدائيته ضد ايران
وتطالب عزل ايران رغم ان موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي ليس كذلك ولماذا لم تذهب الى
شراء الاير باس الاوروبيه على سبيل المثال
وهذا يعطي تماما مثال على رغبه الطرفين في
التقارب على الاقل بحجه البزنس بين
المزدوجين اي من اجل التوصل الى صيغه صيغه
وسط على الامور السياسيه دونالد ترامب
طبعا لديه مصلحه في ان يلبي طموحات
الشركات الامريكيه التي تعمل هناك وهو
عندما يقول فرص عمل فرص عمل فرص عمل
وعندما يتحدث عن امريكا اولا يعتبر ان عقد
صفقات تجاريه مع ايران رغم كل هذا العداء
السياسي بامكانه ان يجلب مزيدا من النمو
الاقتصادي في بلاده يعني الحديث ليس عن
النمو الاقتصادي هذه مصلحه امريكيه نعم
ومن حق الرئيس الامريكي ان يكون حريصا
عليها لكن من حق حلفائه ايضا ان يتقاضوا
ثمنا في مقابل هذه الصفقات في مقابل الدعم
الاقتصادي الولايات المتحده ليست يعني
موقف الولايات المتحده تجاه الايران لا
يشبه موقف مواقف عربيه تجاه ايران
الولايات المتحده لديها مصالح تختلف عن
المصالح العربيه وان كانت الدول العربيه
لا سيما في الاجتماعات التي حصلت في
الرياض مؤخرا تعتبر ان الولايات المتحده
تقترب من الرؤيه الخليجيه بشكل او باخر
هذا يعني عندما نقول تقترب هذا لا يعني
انها تتطابق لذلك اعتقد ان طهران وواشنطن
هم بحاله تبادل رسائل سواء من خلال التشدد
الامريكي او سواء من خلال رسائل الرئيس
الروحاني مؤخرا بضروره التوصل الى نقطه
توازن هذا لا يتناقض ايضا مع اقتراب
الولايات المتحده من الدول الخليجيه كما
اسلفنا في موضوع القمم الثلاث التي عقدت
مؤخرا واعتقد ايضا ان موضوع البزنس سيكون
احد روافد ترتيب العلاقه مجددا مع ايران
لاحظ معي ان ترامب واداره ترامب ليسوا ضد
ايران هم ضد النفوذ الايراني في الخارج
وانهم عندما عندما تقوم ايران بشراء
البوينج الى ايران هذا لا يتناقض مع مصالح
الولايات المتحده قد تتناقض في العراق
وسوريا طيب هذا يفتح الباب امام سؤال
السيد دانيل سيار هل يعني هذا ان اداره
ترامب تسلم بان النفوذ ايراني في اليمن في
سوريا في العراق في لبنان لا يمكن تجاهله
ولا يمكن اي ترتيبات في المنطقه ان تتم
بمعزل عن التعاون مع ايران او على الاقل
الابقاء على مستوى معين من التواصل
معها لم ارى مثل هذا الاعتراف من اداره
ترامب التي كانت اعدائيه لايران فيما
يتعلق ب مساله نشاطاتها الاقليميه ما
اعتقد ان هنالك بعض المجال للتفاهمات
المستقبليه لايران حول مساله المفاوضات في
تمديد الاتفاق النووي الايراني ما يريده
الامريكيون للاتفاق ان يمتد لفتره اطول
وما تم التفاوض عليه في المقام الاول ما
يريده الايرانيون من الامريكيين هو
امكانيه الوصول بشكل اكبر الى النظام
المالي الامريكي وايضا بالنسبه للمصارف
الاوروبيه لكي لا يكون عرضه
للعقبات والنتاج اذا ما تم اذا ما تعامل
مع ايران لذلك اعتقد ان هنالك بعض المجال
للمفاوضات بين ايران وبين الولايات
المتحده لكنها لا تتعلق او لا تتعلق
بمستوى اقل من
النشاطات ايران العدائيه في المنطقه
وتتعلق بشكل اكبر بتمديد الاتفاق النووي
حيث ان الامريكيون لا يريدون لهذا الاتفاق
ان ينتهي في المده التي تم تفاوض عليها
مبدئيا سيد محمد قواص يعني سالتقي طرف
الخيط من ضيفنا من واشنطن عندما يتحدث عن
ان الولايات المتحده تنظر بعين القلق الى
الانشطه العدائيه لايران في المنطقه دعني
انقل لك نصا ما كتبته نيويورك تايمز في
تقريرها تقول انه في مايو الجاري وفي
ابريل الماضي وقع ترامب هدوء اوامر حاسمه
برفع عقوبات عن طهران من شانها ان تحافظ
على الاتفاق النووي وتمكن ايران من ابرام
صفقات تجاريه دوليه والوصول الى اموالها
المجمده من قبل الولايات المتحده اي قلق
يعتري الولايات المتحده وهي تقدم على مثل
هذه الخطوات ومؤخرا في الحقيقه في الوقت
الذي كان يتحدث فيه ترامب بدائيه عن ايران
كانت هذه الامور تتم في هدوء
شديد استاذ محمود نحن طبعا نعرف تاريخ
العلاقه الامريكيه الايرانيه حتى منذ يعني
قيام الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران ونعرف
موضوع
الكونترا ايران الايران جيت ونعرف موضوع
عدم تناقض العلاقه الامريكيه الايرانيه
الى هذه الدرجه كنا نعتبر ان ان الولايات
المتحده تحظى بهذا البعبع الايراني لكي
تبيع تبيع سلاحا في منطقه الخليج وحتى
هناك بعض المعلقين الامريكيين كان يتحدثون
لو لم تكن ا لكنا يجب ان نوجد في هذه
المنطقه ايران فهذا على المستوى الاول
المستوى الثاني ان ايران لا تشكل ابدا حتى
في برنامجها النوويه وحتى في قنبلتها
النوويه اي خطر استراتيجي على الولايات
المتحده ولا حتى على دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
حتى الان ليس لم تجد لم لم تصل يعني مدى
الصواريخ الى هذ الى هذه الدرجه هل على هل
على اذا بناء على هذا الكلام هل على
الحلفاء العرب للولايات المتحده ان يتحسس
مواضع اقدام هم الا يسلموا او يضعوا كل
بيضهم في سله
واشنطن يعني افترض ان الحلفاء العرب الذين
خبروا الاداره الامريكيه لا يمكن ابدا ان
يثقوا بهذه الاداره اولا بشكل منطقي
الاداره الامريكيه ليس لديها مصلحه الا
المصلحه الامريكيه وبالتالي على الحلفاء
العرب ان يقربوا الموقف الامريكي من
موقفهم دون ان يعتبروا ان الولايات
المتحده بامكانها ان
تقاتل مكانهم وبالتالي ايضا خطاب الرئيس
ترامب في الرياض كان واضحا انه عليكم ان
تتحركوا ولن نقاتل اي مكانكم وهذا طبعا
رساله واضحه من للولايات المتحده لاحظ معي
ايضا ان الولايات المتحده حاليا لم تقم
باي ضغط واضح على ايران حتى في موضوع اي
في موضوع اليمني او السوري او العراقي
يعني يعني بعاد تلك الغاره الاخيره التي
استهدفت ميليشيات تابعه لايران قريبا من
الحدود العراقيه الاردنيه السوريه لم نشهد
اي اي اي تصادم ايه
امريكي امريكي ايراني لدينا شعور ان
الولايات المتحده وايران تتعايش حاليا في
العراق وان هناك الطرف الروسي الذي ينظم
هذه العلاقه الجديده بين الولايات المتحده
وايران اعتقد ان الوقت لم يحن بعد لفهم
هذه السياسه الامريكيه التي اصبتم جدا
عندما اعتبرتم انها سياسه حتى الان غامضه
غامضه بالنسبه للموضوع
الايران ماذا ماذا تعني بالوقت مبكر لفهم
هذه السياسه
يعني حتى الان لا نعرف الا الاشارات يعني
كل يوم نتابع التصريحات تصريح الشهير ل
لوزير الخارجيه الذي يقول سارد على على
مكالمه وزير الخارجيه الايراني لكنني لن
اتصل به وبالتالي وكانه هناك دلع متبادل
في هذا الشان طبعا يعني اعود الى الى الى
الى ملاحظتي الاولى حول
قيام ايران التي تعتبر الولايات المتحده
الشيطان الاكبر بالذهاب الى الى شراء
البينج وليس الاير وبالتالي هناك وحده حال
اعتقد تحاول ايران والولايات المتحده ان
تصل اليها المشكله بين ايران والولايات
المتحده و انهم فقدوا نقطه التوازن التي
كانت موجوده قبل ذلك حاليا هم يفتشون عن
هذه
النقطه بروفيسور دانيل سروار باختصار لو
تكرمت متى يمكن فهم او تكوين استراتيجيه
امريكيه متماسكه واضحه المعالم يطابق
ظاهرها باطنها او تطابق الاخوال فيها
الافعال تجاه ايران
لا اتوقع
بالضروره
تناغما او اتساقا من سياسه ترامب التي
يبدو انها تفقد تفتقد هذا الامر لكننا يجب
ان لا نتوقع مثلا ان لا تتم صفقه البوينج
مثلا اذا ما قام ترامب باعاقه هذا الاتفاق
لربما ايرس يقوموا بهذه المبيعات لذلك من
غير المنطقي
للامريكيين ان يقوموا باعاقه هذه الصفقه
مثلا البروفيسور دانيل سروار استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه جونز هوبكنز كان
معنا من واشنطن اشكرك شكرا جزيلا واشكر
ضيفنا من لندن عبر الهاتف المحلل السياسي
محمد قواص